[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'analyse sur Public Sénat
sens public des experts qui donnent du
sens à l'actualité 90 minutes et deux
thèmes d'actu ce soir la loi sur
l'immigration pour commencer présenter
hier en conseil des ministres et elle
veut à la fois faciliter l'expulsion des
délinquants étrangers et regulariser ce
qui travaille dans notre pays depuis
plus de trois ans méchant avec les
méchants gentils avec les gentils le
ministre d'armanin l'argument est
simpliste mais pour l'instant au
Parlement il ne convaincent ni la gauche
ni la droite on décortique ce texte dans
une minute et puis c'est un vote
historique la liberté de la femme de
mettre fin à sa grossesse pourra être
inscrite dans la Constitution les
sénateurs et les sénatrices l'ont décidé
hier soir
j'étais très très émue à la sortie du
vote vous le disiez c'était c'était
inattendu mais c'était pas impossible on
y croyait c'est pour ça qu'on l'a fait
et c'est ses émotions qu'on a quand on
est dans un moment qu'on sait historique
faut-il constitutionnaliser le droit à
l'avortement dans quel pays est-il
menacé faudra-t-il passer par un
référendum pour valider le vote du
Parlement ne ratez pas notre second
débat dans 45 minutes mais d'abord donc
le contenu de la loi immigration et les
réactions détaillées résumé par
Pierre-Henri holderborn
c'est un texte équilibré entre fermeté
et humanité ce sont les mots du
gouvernement pour parler du projet de
loi immigration d'un côté l'exécutif
propose de lutter contre l'immigration
illégale en facilitant les expulsions et
surtout celles des étrangers délinquants
de quoi convaincre la droite sénatoriale
on va regarder dans le détail
naturellement mais c'est déjà une
avancée en matière d'asile comment
limiter les demandes d'asile abusives je
dis bien abusives 135 000 demandes
encore finalement dans un accord d'à peu
près entre 25 et 30000 35000 quand c'est
très compliqué mais ça crée ça irrite
exactement toute l'immigration
irrégulière en tout cas pour ceux qui
sont en fusées mais les LR ne veulent
pas du volley de l'intégration sur le
travail la loi propose aux demandeurs
d'asile sans papiers de travailler dès
leur arrivée mais aussi la création de
titre de séjour pour les travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension des mesures
qui pourtant plaisent à gauche c'est
sénateurs avaient pu le dire à
l'exécutif lors d'un débat nous ne
voulons pas de quota et nous serons
vigil sur cette affaire de liste des
métiers en tension le gouvernement
serait prêt donc à accueillir des
étrangers mais à une condition leur
utilité pour nous il ne doit pas s'agir
de régulariser des pratiques
d'exploitation patronales c'est donc
toute la difficulté de l'exécutif
maintenir les deux volets de son texte
sans braquer la gauche et la droite le
projet de loi doit être examiné en
premier au Sénat dès le mois prochain et
donc je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce premier débat Jean-Yves
Leconte bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sénateur socialiste des Français établis
hors de France Rachel binias bonsoir
bienvenue journaliste au service société
au magazine Marianne Didier leski
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
directeur général de l'Office français
de l'immigration et de l'intégration et
Mathilde Sirault bonsoir Mathilde
éditorialiste politique pour sens
publique peut-être une réaction un peu
générale on va ensuite prendre le temps
de décortiquer les les grandes mesures
de ce texte Jean-Yves Leconte et si vous
parlez à la hauteur des enjeux de
l'immigration aujourd'hui non c'est un
texte de com enfin bon déjà quand on
quand on dit être gentil avec les
gentils méchant avec les méchants ça me
montre une maîtrise assez limitée
finalement de la complexité alors que
c'est un sujet complexe deuxièmement
sur la partie éloignement
je pense qu'au contraire si on veut
faire des abonnements efficaces pour
protéger l'ordre public il faut savoir
se concentrer sur ce qui est nécessaire
et pas vouloir tout faire
parce que on arrivera à rien donc il
faut prioriser c'est pas l'esprit global
du texte pour ce qui est du droit
d'asile la remise en cause
de de la possibilité de faire appel à
une formation de jugement collectif dans
un certain nombre de cas et donc la
place du FCR dans la Cour nationale du
droit d'asile remettre ça en cause ça me
semble dangereux sur la partie travail
bien entendu j'y suis plus favorable
d'avoir c'est une question d'ordre
public là encore de permettre aux
personne qui travaille en situation
irrégulière et qui sont en situation
irrégulière d'être dans un certain
nombre de sous un certain nombre de
conditions d'obtenir une possibilité
d'être régularisé donc ça ça me semble
plutôt être dans la bonne direction
toutefois moi je crois à la capacité du
travail comme avec vecteur fondamental
d'intégration et je pense que on ne va
pas au bout des choses alors vous avez
l'occasion de de droit du travail au
droit au travail des demandeurs d'asile
on y reviendra sur ces différents
aspects et vous pourrez détailler et
finalement vos arguments Rachel binias
le en même temps macronie c'est ce qui
peut s'appliquer à l'immigration c'est
un peu la question ça pourrait être la
question générale de cette limite de
cette émission vous qui êtes voilà qui
est enquêté sur ces questions comment
vous ressentez ce texte mais c'est un
texte qui comme très souvent quand on
aborde cette question là de
l'immigration qui est une question
éminemment passionnelle et ou parfois le
problème c'est que c'est mouvoir semble
dispenser de réfléchir c'est une
question qui amène des confrontations
politiques et idéologiques qui
ressurgissent c'est pas toujours le cas
avec avec ce sujet là
c'est à dire des questions comme est-il
légitime ou pas de renvoyer d'éloigner
des clandestins ou est-ce qu'à partir du
moment où une personne est en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire à partir
du moment où à la franchi la frontière
et de fait il faudrait la régulariser
est-ce que justement
augmenter les exigences à l'égard de ces
gens qui arrivent et légitimes ou pas
est-ce que ça peut permettre
l'intégration et où en étant sur la
langue française sur la langue française
exactement on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais c'est aussi une loi qui
vient à un moment où on le sait et bien
le le pacte républicain en matière
d'intégration et particulièrement
fragile maintenant la question vous
l'avez dit c'est est-ce que cette loi et
cette espèce d'en même temps peut tenir
ou pas est-ce qu'il peut séduire ou pas
ça va être extrêmement compliqué pour
pour le gouvernement et même pour la
majorité Didier leski c'est il était
incarné au départ par deux ministres ce
texte Gérald Darmanin et l'idée du soft
mise à l'intérieur ministre du Travail
il y avait même c'est en même temps il
était même physiquement visible des
Français on a l'impression qu'Olivier du
sorte accaparé par la réforme des
retraites un peu disparu
écoutez ça c'est votre appréciation de
journaliste mais ce qui est important
dans ce texte et dans le débat public
c'est de remettre la question du travail
avec l'immigration puisque
historiquement l'intégration des
immigrés c'est fait par le travail et
nous avons toujours une immigration de
travail importante puisque les chiffres
de 2022 c'est plus de 55000 personnes
qui sont rentrés en France par le biais
du travail voilà ce que propose le texte
c'est la régularisation de ceux qui sont
ici c'est un mécanisme qui est
spécifique à la France puisqu'on est un
des rares pays à avoir déjà un processus
de régulation
régularisation au fil de l'eau d'autres
pays ne l'ont pas on peut penser par
exemple à l'Allemagne qui du coup va
être obligé de faire une opération des
régularisation beaucoup plus massive
parce qu'ils n'ont pas ce ce système de
régularisation et enfin l'ensemble des
pays européens de l'Union européenne
sont confrontés à une situation qu'on
connaît si vous voulez sur la longue
durée c'est qu'il y a une part de
l'immigration qui est la projection du
chaos du monde et dans ce cas ou du
monde le continent où les pays qui sont
enviés c'est plutôt l'Union européenne
on peut reprendre par exemple le
problème de enfin l'exemple de Kaboul
quand le 15 août 2021 Kaboul tombe si
vous voulez aucun afghan raisonnable si
j'ose dire mais enfin aucun afghan il
était tous référent de ses précipités
auprès de l'ambassade de Chine
l'ambassade de Russie pour lui demander
l'Asie tout le monde est devenu en
Europe vous connaissez mieux ils vont
d'abord dans les pays limitrophes
souvent et puis ensuite ils essaient
d'atteindre effectivement l'eldorado
européen ou ils vont ou non sauf parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas aller ailleurs
mais l'envie d'aller ailleurs si vous
voulez il est d'abord une envie de
d'échapper à la situation économique des
astrose au Pakistan à ce qui se passe en
Iran puisqu'on avait par exemple pour
les Afghans une communauté
afghane importante en Iran c'est tout ça
qu'il faut gérer c'est pour ça que
l'ensemble des pays européens
connaissent des modifications
législatives importantes et et parfois
même radical par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
connaître on peut se souvenir par
exemple que au début des années 1980
pour les plus anciens d'entre nous les
Pays-Bas étaient vécus comme le pays
extrêmement accueillant pour
l'immigration aujourd'hui les mécanismes
juridiques met en place au Pays-Bas sont
extrêmement contraignantes par rapport à
ce qu'on connaît nous je rappelle que au
Pays-Bas même pour le regroupement
familial ou l'immigration familiale on
ne peut pas avoir un visa si on n'a pas
déjà appris un minimum de de Hollandais
et même pour les nationaux hollandais si
on n'a pas un appartement suffisamment
grand et si on n'a pas de revenus et
bien on peut pas faire venir un conjoint
une conjointe étrangère Mathilde et
intervenir vous parliez de du cas de
l'Allemagne et de l'immigration avec le
la question du travail il y a une
question souvent qui revient et même un
postulat qui serait de dire que
l'économie française ne pourrait pas
tourner sans l'immigration est-ce que ça
vous pouvez l'illustrer et ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec très longue durée il
y a toujours eu une immigration de
travail en particulier une migration de
travail dans des secteurs pénibles et
dans des secteurs de peu de
qualification la difficulté que nous
avons depuis le début des années 80 en
particulier c'est la
désindustrialisation de la France en
même temps qu'il y a une augmentation et
une concentration de l'immigration dans
certains départements ou dans certains
lieux la Seine-Saint-Denis par exemple
la Seine-Saint-Denis au début des années
70 dans le nombre d'immigrés c'est le 9e
département de France aujourd'hui c'est
le deuxième département de France parce
que on a eu une montée de l'immigration
qui était dû à deux choses
l'expulsion des immigrés de Paris d'une
certaine manière des pauvres en même
temps que cette ville se dit
accueillante elle expulse ses pauvres et
en particulier les immigrés donc Paris
c'était 30% d'immigrés au début des
années 80 c'est aujourd'hui 20% avec une
part importante de européen et en même
temps les immigrés du Sud ils sont allés
en Seine-Saint-Denis et au moment ils
sont allés en Seine-Saint-Denis on a
fermé les usines de voitures et on a
fait disparaître ce qui était les
emplois peu qualifiés on appelait cela
les ouvriers spécialisés les es dans les
spécialisation était de ne pas en avoir
c'est la fermeture à partir depuis 1983
des usines automobiles et qui s'est
étalé jusque aux années 2000 et ces
usines automobiles où est-ce qu'elles se
trouvent aujourd'hui elle se trouve en
Algérie au Maroc c'est à dire dépays
départ et ceux qui partent sont soit des
classes moyennes qui ne veulent plus
vivre dans ces pays parce que on y vit
mal soit les perdants du système puisque
dans cette projection du chaos du monde
et bien on a la faillite de fait d'État
qui était pourtant porteur de plein
d'espérance alors on va écouter le
ministre de l'Intérieur reprend cette
formule qui était faite pour frapper les
esprits ça marche puisqu'on y fait
toujours référence les gentils et les
méchants écoutez j'ai résumé les choses
dans le journal Le Monde en disant que
nous devions être désormais gentille
avec les gens disent c'est avec les
étrangers qui veulent travailler en
France respecter nos règles parler notre
langue être amoureux notre drapeau et
puis s'ils font des enfants qui le
viennent nourrir la longue corde de ceux
qui ont eu comme moi des grands-parents
émigrés qui sont venus en France pour
travailler courageusement et et être
méchant avec les méchant c'est à dire
que nous devons ne pas accepter que
quelqu'un qui ne veut pas s'intégrer qui
ne respecte pas nos règles qui commet
des actes de vacances ne doit pas rester
sur le sol national
Jean-Yves Leconte la dernière partie de
la de la phrase de Gérald Darmanin voilà
cette partie répressive est-ce qu'elle
est pas tout simplement dehors du bon
sens de toute façon enfin quand on
entend comme ça on se dit bah oui c'est
gentil c'est une fable parce que c'est
quand même quelque chose d'éminemment
complexe bien entendu quand on l'écoute
de cette manière le mix de l'intérieur
on dit bah oui c'est logique sauf que
c'est un peu plus complexe sur sur la
partie
par exemple expulsion bien entendu on va
pas dire toute personne qui est en
situation irrégulière devrait pouvoir
être en situation régulière d'un autre
côté parce qu'on comprend bien ce que ça
veut dire derrière les applications donc
et le sens finalement de ce que veut
dire régulier irrégulier dans ce cas là
toutefois à partir du moment où on on
veut on affirme des questions en
particulier d'ordre public je les
partage sauf qu'il faut savoir où est-ce
qu'on met le curseur il faut savoir s'il
s'agit de suspicion de se juger enfin
bref il faut mettre du droit là-dedans
c'est passé simple que ça je partage
vous dites que c'est de la com c'est
pour ça que je dis que c'est de la come
tiens moi je crois que sur ce sujet là
on peut faire beaucoup plus j'ai quand
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur fait
une circulaire en disant toute personne
qui est en situation irrégulière vous
mettez des occultés vous les mettez en
crainte etc quand on fait ça qu'on
surcharge l'écran on oblige les gens
pardon les centres de rétention
administratives quand on fait ça de
cette manière là on ne priorise pas ceux
qui devraient être
expulsés pour des raisons de sécurité ça
c'est une vraie question c'est moi je
pense que la priorité c'est la
priorisation c'est le fait de faire en
sorte que la police de l'air et des
frontières que nos services
diplomatiques soient mobilisés sur les
cas les plus essentiels et d'autre part
mettre le paquet le paquet parce que je
je crois fondamentalement et je rejoins
que on est peut-être dans une nouvelle
période par rapport à ce que Monsieur
consommateur de l'OFI disait sur
finalement l'intégration par le travail
effectivement on est passé par une
période de désindustrialisation on voit
aujourd'hui que notre économie a plus
besoin et l'économie européenne d'une
manière générale à plus besoin
finalement de main d'oeuvre par
conséquent c'est une il faut revoir
réinvestir finalement recroire on le
fait que le travail est un moyen
d'intégration et ce donner donc les
moyens d'être capable de donner des des
situations régulières et ne pas être
inquiets sur une chose sur les sur en
particulier la régularisation avoir des
gens qui travaillent de manière
régulière ce n'est pas d'une de mix
sociale c'est lutter contre le dumping
des salaires
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec les
protégés temporaires ukrainiens et
protéger temporaires ukrainien ils ont
eu le droit de travailler immédiatement
est-ce qu'on a est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est plus facile comme ça c'est
plus facile comme ça donc vraiment sur
le droit au travail et la capacité du
travail d'intégrer il faut y aller il
faut arrêter de rentrer on revient sur
les hôpitaux les obligations de quitter
le territoire français est-ce que est-ce
qu'on en distribue trop pour que ce soit
finalement efficace
la question n'est pas dans distribuer
trop ou pas c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut prendre le problème prenez par
exemple c'est l'une des critiques qui
exprimée j'entends bien l'année dernière
la France a délivré 130
000 visas pour l'Algérie 140 000 pour le
Maroc dans le même temps il y a eu très
peu de laisser passer consulaire qui ont
été donnés par ces pays pour reprendre
ceux qui n'ont pas l'autorisation de
séjour ici et qui ont en l'occurrence
ont eu des auqtf je crois que c'est 20
000 pour les Algériens quelque chose
comme ça si on veut qu'il y ait une
migration circulaire ça suppose qu'il y
ait
une responsabilisation et une rapport de
confiance si on donne avec d'origine
avec les pays d'origine or qu'est-ce qui
se passe ces pays ne veulent pas soit
reprendre leur perdants sans reprendre
leur les personnes dont elles peuvent
penser à un moment donné et bien qu'elle
remettront en cause un système social
qui est profondément une égalitaire
c'est ça qui se passe voilà et donc la
question qui nous est posée c'est de
savoir effectivement si on peut admettre
cette décidé que toute personne qui met
le pied en Europe et bien doit être au
bout du compte régularisé et qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire du point de vue de
l'organisation sociale générale ou
est-ce que on fait pression sur ces pays
en disant vous ne pouvez pas continuer à
être des pays aussi inégalités que cela
et qui fait que les deux principales
nationalités qui passent en Espagne ces
dernières années ce sont les Algériens
les Marocains alors il y a une dimension
politique dont on va parler maintenant
avec vous Mathilde puisque on l'a bien
compris quand sans doute plus sur la
droite pour voter cette loi immigration
mais il pourrait le ministre à
l'intérieur de venir en quelque sorte la
victime collatérale de du débat sur la
réforme des retraites oui Thomas le
ministre à l'intérieur donc on le sait
il est venu des rangs des républicains
il est toujours proche de Nicolas
Sarkozy mais aussi de Xavier Bertrand il
soumettra on l'a dit le texte en premier
lieu au sénateur c'est une stratégie qui
vise en fait à piéger la droite en
tentant d'embarquer avec lui les troupes
de Gérard Larcher et de Bruno Retailleau
moyennant des concessions et en
durcissement du texte il espère ainsi
pouvoir mettre la pression ensuite sur
l'Assemblée sur les députés LR puisque
Gérald Darmanin a fait ses calculs il a
besoin de 50 abstentions du côté Dr pour
que sa loi soit adoptée à l'Assemblée
voilà ça c'est le plan de départ sauf
que depuis que le parti direction tique
accepté de pactiser avec le gouvernement
sur la question des retraites même si
cette alliance se révèle on l'a vu
plutôt fragile la droite est condamnée à
se démarquer de l'exécutif sur cette
question de l'immigration qui est un
sujet on le sait très identitaire pour
son électorat d'ailleurs le RN en fait
déjà son miel et pilonne un parti qui
serait devenu devenu je cite la béquille
d'Emmanuel Macron alors c'est à dire que
finalement le OUI au retraite déclenche
automatiquement en réaction un nom sur
l'immigration qui est un nom plutôt de
posture plus que de conviction et sans
la droite le gouvernement risque de
devoir passer en force Elisabeth borne
sacrifiera tel son dernier 49,3 sur le
texte immigration au risque de de
s'exposer à une motion de censure est-ce
que le gouvernement sera contraint de
faire machine arrière ce sont des
questions aujourd'hui qui se posent tous
les scénarios sont possibles en disant
vouloir aller très loin sur le volet
régularisation et très loin sur le volet
fermeté et expulsion le gouvernement
perd finalement sur les deux tableaux à
la fois la droite et la gauche puisque
cette fameuse stratégie due en même
temps ce hurt à la réalité de la
majorité relative le rapport de force
politique finalement déterminera
l'avenir de cette loi Gérald Darmanin
sera certainement contraint d'amoindrir
tout ou partie des mesures qui visent à
régulariser certains travailleurs sans
papiers au risque de s'alliéner les
voies de l'algorge et la majorité qui
déjà rechigne
une nouvelle fois sur ce thème qui on se
souvient avait suscité beaucoup de
crispations lors de la loi colon en 2018
bref la configuration politique est très
complexe l'issue paraît à ce stade
inextricable sur un sujet très sensible
dans l'opinion et sur lequel le
président n'a jamais vraiment réussi à
convaincre jusqu'à maintenant et encore
moins à obtenir des résultats quand bien
même on connaît la difficulté réelle
merci Mathilde c'est intéressant parce
que vous nous dites qui va encore
évoluer et être négocié or il a déjà été
apprenant négocié en interne en quelque
sorte au sein de la majorité
présidentielle c'est ce que dit
Sacha Oli qui est le président
renaissance de la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée écoutez le projet de loi
initial de la loopnine et prévoyez que
les expulsions des excuses étrangers
délinquants et que ils prévoient
désormais la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension vous imaginez que ce
point n'est pas apparu par l'opération
du Saint-Esprit et que il a été
apprenant négocié des mois durant avec
le ministère de l'Intérieur et que je
pense que les dixièmes de milliers de
travailleurs qui aujourd'hui sont dans
les cuisines sont sur des chantiers
voire même selon les soins hospitaliers
infirmiers ou dans les EHPAD voire des
médecins et bien seront ravis
d'apprendre que ils n'auront plus besoin
de travailler sous alias
si la droite et la gauche le rejet c'est
peut-être qu'il était équilibré
effectivement ce texte sur l'immigration
est-ce que vous reprenez ce que nous
disait à l'instant Mathilde c'est-à-dire
que ils font tout droit vers le 49-3
alors je il y a quand même un grand
point d'interrogation autour du 49-3
parce que il semblerait que la première
ministre ne soit pas enchanté à l'idée
d'utiliser pour ce type de texte
particulièrement le 49-3 donc en effet
c'est une équation qui pour le
gouvernement paraît extrêmement
compliquée à résoudre renforcé le texte
c'est-à-dire le durcir pour séduire un
des députés des parlementaires LR mais
avec le risque qu'une partie de la
majorité ne veuille pas le voter ou
alors rester sur cette espèce de dans
même temps qui paraît aussi difficile à
tenir puisque l'air de toute façon n'ont
aucun intérêt à s'abstenir sur ce type
de thématique un mot quand même sur le
sur le travail parce que on en parle on
a deux hommes de gauche sur le sur le
plateau et je suis je ne pense pas je ne
sais pas ça ne l'est pas ça ne l'est pas
dans la bouche et je suis assez surprise
que alors certes on parle de régulariser
les personnes qui travaillent c'est
plein de bons sentiments et ça peut être
légitime sur le papier mais il y a quand
même une chose aussi oui que des bons
sentiments certes mais il y a une chose
qu'on aborde pas et qui fait partie même
du projet c'est deux choses c'est ce
qu'on appelle les métiers en tension et
c'est ce qu'on appelle le titre talent
professions médicales métiers en tension
qui permettrait alors on n'a pas encore
la liste de faciliter justement l'accès
et le séjour des personnes qui se
tourneraient vers des métiers qui
aujourd'hui ont du mal à trouver
justement à trouver des du personnel
aussi parce que les conditions de
travail ne sont pas toujours idéales
parce que les salaires ne sont pas
extrêmement bons et parce que de manière
générale le code du travail est parfois
et parfois utiliser de manière assez
aléatoire et puis ce titre ce titre de
talent professions médicales et
pharmacie qui en fait va vider va
provoquer une espèce d'exode qui existe
déjà mais c'est une espèce d'exode qui
semble assumer
22000 médecins aujourd'hui on ne prenons
que la Tunisie la Tunisie le nombre de
médecins qu'elle forme chaque année ça
correspond au nombre de médecins qui
part qui part pour travailler notamment
ça peut être Canada France golfe
Persique c'est une question est-ce qu'on
accepte peut-être mais dans ce cas là il
faut que ce soit clair de vider certains
pays de leur élite de leur matière grise
sur un sujet aussi
complexe aussi important que que la
santé
alors les questions les deux questions
sont légitimes toutefois moi je vais
vous faire une réponse très claire si on
considère que parce que vous dites ça il
faut absolument pas accepter les talents
dans le domaine de la santé
[Musique]
un accueille pas s'ils veulent partir
ils partiront ailleurs donc moi j'ai
aucun état d'âme sur ce sur ce sujet et
sur le deuxième point sur le deuxième
point il est clair que effectivement sur
un certain nombre de métiers en tension
où il y a une bonne partie des personnes
qui travaillent aujourd'hui de manière
irrégulière qui dépend de leur employeur
et qui donc acceptent des conditions de
travail que ce soit en termes d'horaire
ou que ce soit en termes de salaire qui
sont inacceptables le jour où ces
personnes sont régularisées il y aura
plus le même dumping et les conditions
de travail seront donc améliorées les
conditions de travail général dans le
secteur s'amélioreront plus cette idée
de je refuse cette idée de trappes à bas
salaire au contraire si on régularise si
on fait que dans des un certain nombre
de métiers où on sait qu'aujourd'hui
d'une partie significative des personnes
qui travaillent de manière irrégulière
dans des situations de quasi esclavage
qui ne peuvent pas faire valoir leur
droit parce qu'ils sont les situations
irrégulières le jour où les personnes
sont en situation irrégulière ça change
la donne et ça change la donne pour tout
le monde ça donne
il y a deux aspects qui sont
aussi intéressant l'un que l'autre on
reviendra sur les métiers en tension
mais sur c'est effectivement l'aspect
des on va dire des des talents notamment
des talents médicaux qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à la à la critique ou à
l'intervention de Rachel bignard sur le
thème bah oui mais on appauvrit on
appauvri ces pays qu'est-ce qu'on fait
je sais pas si je suis un homme de
gauche comme le dit
critique dans la bouche mais bien
évidemment c'est une victoriation qu'on
peut avoir parce que on sait bien qu'il
y a des médecins qui viennent mais une
chose est d'avoir des médecins qui
viennent et du reste l'OFI participe de
la venue de ces médecins par exemple en
Tunisie et au moment de de la crise du
covid j'étais un peu perturbé je dirais
parce que on continue à faire venir des
médecins et en même temps vous
journaliste vous faisiez des reportages
sur la situation du covid en Tunisie on
voyait ces hôpitaux sans médecins avec
des Tunisiens qui étaient dans une
situation extrêmement difficile et donc
le problème n'est pas que des médecins
viennent et enfin je veux dire j'entends
bien ce que dit Rachel binasse le
problème de savoir si on l'affiche voilà
et comment on l'affiche et quel est
l'écho de cette affichage dans les pays
de départ or nous avons une difficulté
dans toute l'Afrique et c'est
particulièrement vrai dans certains pays
du Maghreb ou par exemple des parties
islamistes disent que fait la France
elle a une politique post-coloniale
affichée de faire venir spécifiquement
en plus sur une profession qui qui
touche au corps et à la santé des gens
un des médecins pour les aspirer et et
c'est peut-être là où il y a un problème
sans doute en tout cas il devrait y
avoir un effort d'explication pour dire
ce n'est pas une politique post
coloniale que de d'afficher très
clairement que nous voulons aspirer vos
médecins mais est-ce qu'on est
effectivement dans une concurrence
internationale parce que c'est un sujet
on sait bien que on est d'autant plus en
confiance internationale que
l'administration de la santé est sans
doute les responsables politiques de
l'époque ont fait une erreur tragique
pour nous pour nous tous collectivement
c'est en 1970 71 la mise en place de ce
qu'on appelle le numerus clausus qui
était qui est tombé extrêmement bas sur
le nombre de médecins formés et
aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière vous
seriez algérien tunisien sénégalais
camerounais et bien vous pourriez dire
la France en faisant venir mes médecins
me fait payer son étreur stratégique il
y a presque 40 ans et et essaye de
combler ses déserts médicaux par le
biais de gens dont elle ne paye pas la
formation je dis ça parce que il y a eu
une tribune de médecin qui travaille
avec l'OFI donc sa vieille manuellier et
d'autres dans le Journal du Dimanche et
ils l'ont fait en toute indépendance
puisque les médecins de l'Office ont
indépendants et qui soulignait tout ça
Rony Brauman avec etc et je pense que
c'est une interrogation légitime après
il m'appartient pas de critiquer le
projet du gouvernement allez-y et
j'ajoute aussi d'une manière un peu plus
générale que pour les pays de départ les
pays qui perdraient un certain nombre de
cerveaux qui perdent qui perdent un
certain nombre de cerveaux finalement on
doit constater qu'à la sortie il y a
plus finalement ces pays ont aussi
finalement besoin de leur diaspora ne
serait-ce qu'en terme financière et en
termes de développement
l'aide l'accompagnement les financements
des diaspora est supérieur à les publics
au développement et souvent sur des
projets qui sont plus adaptés qui sont
pas dirigés qui sont pas organisés par
des États qui sont souvent pas
absolument idéales pour le bonheur de
leur population et par conséquent
finalement c'est avoir une diaspora
forte enfin un médecin c'est aussi c'est
aussi la capacité de se développer
soi-même un pays qui a une diasporaphore
c'est aussi un pays qui a de la force de
se développer parce qu'il y a de la
mobilité et parce qu'il y a des moyens
des financements qui sont qui sont
adéquats pour le développement du pays
donc voilà c'est je je ne dis pas ça
juste méchamment je constate simplement
que les personnes qui veulent partir
elles partiront ça fait partie de la
liberté individuelle et qu'à partir de
là on doit essayer de s'organiser avec
ces contrats alors l'autre aspect et on
va prendre le temps de d'en débattre et
de détailler les mesures c'est
effectivement la régularisation de ces
travailleurs sans papier qui sont en
France depuis plus de 3 ans dans les
dans les secteurs en tension notamment
ce titre de séjour métier en tension
alors il fait évidemment bondir Eric
ceci on l'écoute j'ai déjà dit que je ne
voterai pas ce texte pourquoi parce que
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à une
Bérézina migratoire les chiffres ont été
publiés là on est dans la com gentil
avec les gentils méchants avec les
méchants c'est impuissant avec tout le
monde
les chiffres sont sortis c'était jeudi
ou vendredi dernier ils viennent du
ministère de l'Intérieur 320
000 titres de séjour accordés par
Monsieur Darmanin en 2022 auquel se
rajoute 156 000 demandeurs d'asile on
s'interdit rien mais en tout cas moi je
ne consomme pas un texte qui va
régulariser 30 à 40 000 étrangers en
situation irrégulière pourquoi parce que
conduit un appel d'air alors cette
question de l'appel des rois évidemment
parler mais d'abord je propose à Mathias
Arras de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
il est là juste derrière le rideau
bonsoir Mathias bienvenue ce titre de de
séjour sur les métiers en tension déjà
est-ce qu'on est des pionniers est-ce
que c'est une exception française
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire non la
France n'aura pas la primauté en Europe
l'Italie l'Espagne l'Allemagne
l'Angleterre en réalité face au
vieillissement généralisé de la
population et au manque de main d'oeuvre
quasiment tous les pays ou presque font
et continueront de faire appel à
l'immigration dans les années à venir
deux modèles toutefois ceux qui ont une
urgence immédiate et régularise les
immigrés déjà présents et ceux qui
prévoient d'en accueillir de nouveaux
grâce à de nouvelles lois de quel modèle
ce le projet français se rapproche et
bien le projet de loi français est très
proche de ce qu'applique l'Espagne
depuis l'été dernier là-bas les
personnes en situation irrégulières
pouvant prouver qu'elles vivent depuis
au moins deux ans dans le pays pourront
prétendre à un titre de séjour
temporaire si elle s'engage à suivre une
formation dans les secteurs tendus que
sont l'hôtellerie le BTP ou encore
l'agriculture en Italie c'est un peu la
même solution pour les métiers peu
qualifiés toutefois cette politique
migratoire elle pourrait être remise en
cause avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de
Georgia Meloni et alors qu'est-ce qui
nous
différencie de ce que propose
l'Angleterre ou l'Allemagne et bien ces
deux pays se rapprochent plus du modèle
canadien avec un système par point par
les la langue justifiée une promesse
d'embauche ou encore avoir de
l'expérience dans un métier en tension
seront des plus pour espérer obtenir une
régularisation rapide ici l'effet va
donc plus loin car on espère attirer des
personnes ne se trouvant pas dans le
territoire national à l'inverse de la
France l'Allemagne qui vise les 400 000
travailleurs qualifiés par an ce rêve
selon les mots de son chancelier au lave
Scholtz en pays d'immigrations modernes
merci Mathias pays d'immigration moderne
je reprends cette formule Didier
esquisse a rejoint ce que vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
face au cas où du monde on peut toujours
toujours faire la politique de
l'autruche mais il y aura des des vagues
migratoires on parle de il y en a déjà
de futurs réfugiés climatiques bref un
pays d'immigration moderne peut pas
appliquer les mêmes
méthodes aujourd'hui que celle des
années 90 ou 2000
les difficultés c'est que chaque pays a
une immigration particulière et par
exemple quand on parle de l'Espagne on a
une situation un peu particulière
puisque on l'oublie souvent la troisième
nationalité qui rentre en Europe en
termes de demande d'asile ce sont des ce
sont des latinos américains ce sont des
Vénusiens des Colombiens qui passent par
l'Espagne prioritairement bien sûr c'est
logique ce qui rentre en Espagne sont
sans visa en fait et on oublie du reste
que les venezueliens constituent la
constitue la une des toutes premières
nationalités en errance justement du
fait de la faillite du modèle
vénézuélien et donc la question de
l'intégration en Espagne pour ceux qui
arrivent et est assez différente de
l'immigration qu'on a nous donc quand on
compare d'un pays à l'autre en fait il
faut compter c'est compliqué on peut pas
appliquer les mêmes méthodes que les
Marocains les Algériens qui ont
particulier algériens qui traversent la
Méditerranée en fait ne reste pas en en
Espagne et traversent après les Pyrénées
et viennent plutôt en français nous la
difficulté que nous avons c'est une main
d'oeuvre qualifié
qui est là et les Allemands par exemple
leur immigration elle est d'abord
européenne au sens large elle vient de
l'ancienne Fédération de Russie des
Roumains des Polonais alors que nous nos
premières immigrations et bien viennent
de pays dont on peut pas dire que les
systèmes en particulier les systèmes
scolaires soit particulièrement bon en
ce qui concerne la masse des gens il y a
une élite formée bien sûr mais c'est pas
ça le sujet donc chaque pays
choisi en fait ou subit des immigrations
particulières les Allemands ont décidé
de choisir et prioritairement des
personnes qualifiées avec en plus un
système qui peut être extrêmement dur
beaucoup plus dur que nous en ce qui
concerne l'immigration familiale le
droit à l'immigration familiale par
exemple la santé je rappelle que quand
un clandestin va dans un hôpital en
Allemagne bien évidemment s'il y a une
urgence il est pris en charge mais
l'administration de l'hôpital est tenue
de de le dénoncer à la police de l'air
des frontières il y a un pays que vous
n'avez pas cité en terme la politique
migratoire c'est celui le cas de la du
Danemark qui est aussi peut vous
interroger en tant qu'homme de gauche
sur sur ce plateau le revirement en fait
de la gauche
le revirement de la gauche au Danemark
qui qui applique une politique
migratoire très très ferme et qui voilà
qui qui interroge et qui a notamment
inspiré la Fondation Jean Jaurès qui en
qui l'a publié qui a publié une note sur
ce sujet et fond d'appel est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est un modèle qui pourrait
être duplicable en France et qu'est-ce
que ça dit finalement de de l'évolution
peut-être culturelle vis-à-vis de
l'immigration mais en la posant
peut-être à Jean-Yves Leconte et en
rajoutant une dimension est-ce que
finalement le le la gauche française
et d'autres gauches européennes CE sont
pas durci au fur et à mesure c'est à
dire je crois pas
déjà effectivement quand on regarde on a
un bon exemple
le Dan remarque se cache derrière ce
cache derrière l'Allemagne
ça ne peut il est il est il est loin des
pays de première entrée
c'est donc une politique qu'il mène je
crois d'ailleurs que l'étape suivante
qui est de d'envoyer les demandeurs
d'asile Rwanda en tout cas son projet ça
ne peut pas rentrer dans l'endroit
européen
mais ça n'est certainement pas quelque
chose qui peut être fait au niveau de
l'ensemble de de l'Union européenne et
puis nous sommes français nous avons une
entité constitutionnelle nous sommes
attachés aux droits d'asile je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse imaginer d'aller vers
la situation du Danemark moi je peux
vous dire j'ai changé quelques fois avec
des sociaux-démocrates danois
franchement c'est plus facile pour moi
de parler avec
la Ligue italienne qu'avec le
socio-démocrates danois parce que il y a
je sur ce sujet ils ont ils ont ils sont
dans une autre dans dans une autre
dimension je je ne pense je ne peux pas
imaginer que ce soit un modèle voilà
le modèle il est effectivement ça a été
rappelé sur la question de l'intégration
par le travail
et je crois qu'on est justement en 2022
on a beaucoup plus de premiers types de
séjour délivrés pour des raisons de
travail parce que notre économie en
demande c'est la première fois depuis
longtemps ça ça recommence et finalement
je crois qu'il faut être capable
d'accompagner l'évolution et les besoins
de l'économie et croire et et faire en
sorte que ses besoins soient accompagnés
avec une politique d'intégration qui
soit une politique d'interaction
volontaire donc pas en rentrant les
choses compliquées un mot de l'Allemagne
parce que je voyais réagir pendant que
Didier leski et évoquer le modèle c'est
vrai qu'on a souvent l'impression que
l'Allemagne est un pays particulièrement
accueillant c'est plus compliqué que ça
c'est plus compliqué souvent comme ça
que nous autres journalistes avant
l'habitude de présenter les choses mais
en effet on l'a dit l'Allemagne alors
l'Allemagne est historiquement un pays
de droit du sang et pas et de droit du
sol et il s'est à partir des années 2000
que le pays a vraiment ouvert justement
les conditions de nature par exemple
c'est arrivé et c'est arrivé à cet art
les conditions de langue de logement ou
de revenus sont sont bien plus
drastiques qu'en France et en effet il
s'inspire du modèle canadien qui a un
modèle quand même assez élitiste c'est à
dire ou c'est un modèle à points où on
va favoriser eu un certain type un
certain type d'immigration donc pareil
l'Allemagne demande à ce qu'on renonce à
sa nationalité d'origine il y a très peu
la double nationalité et est
exceptionnelle mais ce n'est ce n'est
pas des fois ce n'est pas possible je
vous dis pas si c'est bien ou mal je
vous explique
obtention de la nationalité quand on est
autant qu'on est étranger en Allemagne
on n'a pas besoin d'intégration on parle
d'intégration et donc leur vision leur
vision est particulière par rapport à
celle de la France justement c'est pas
exactement la même on retrouve des
similarités avec l'Italie entre
l'Allemagne et l'Italie un mot parce
qu'en effet le cadanoï est intéressant
et l'évolution de la gauche parce que il
faut savoir que l'ancien ministre de
l'Intégration et de l'immigration
puisqu'ils ont un ministre pour ça mais
Mathias Thaïs Faye qui est le fils d'un
réfugiés éthiopien et qui a commencé qui
a fait ses armes au parti communiste
danois et bien c'est lui qui a l'origine
de cette volonté de cette proposition de
cette mesure de demander justement de
faire examiner sa demande d'asile
notamment au Rwanda alors on va il nous
reste cinq minutes le temps file trop
vite mais ça prouve que le débat est
intéressant enfin j'espère que c'est ce
que vous ressentez devant votre votre
poste de télévision votre ordinateur on
va parler du fonctionnement
effectivement de l'asile et et alors ça
pose la question de du renvoi dans leur
pays l'origine des délinquants et des
procédures pour le faire elles sont
jugées trop compliquées trop de voix de
recours selon le ministre de l'Intérieur
écoutez ce qu'on dit par exemple cette
association Amnesty internationale on
écoute Manon Fillonneau qui est chargé
de plaidoyer migration amnistique
il y a des gens qui jouent leur vie il y
a des gens qui vont pouvoir rentrer dans
leur pays être torturés exécuté s'ils
sont renvoyés dans leur pays donc là on
joue pas des des petits sujets et c'est
trop dangereux que de délivrer des
occupés si vite j'arrive le compte vous
êtes particulièrement critique sur ce
volet de la loi pourquoi bah déjà j'ai
du mal à comprendre votre question parce
que vous parlez à la fois d'asile et
après vous parlez d'occulté F donc quand
on est en demandeur d'asile on dépend en
deuts parce que quand on est le moteur
d'asile on a on peut rester sur le
territoire donc on n'est pas sommeil il
a quitté oui mais on retrouve
en témoigner des personnes qui sont dans
des procédures judiciaires et qui
demande quand même la ville il faut il y
a deux choses différentes il y a la
demande d'asile
et ça effectivement faut accélérer les
demandes d'asile au maximum et puis il y
a ce que ce qu'on évoquait au début
c'est-à-dire les personnes qui
effectivement pour des raisons d'ordre
public doivent être doivent être évacués
et une deuxième sujet qui a mon avis
devrait être aussi prioritaire parmi les
les ce les éloignements c'est les
trouver une solution pour les sortants
de prison
qu'on considère comme ne devons pas
rester sur le territoire parce qu'il est
pas logique qui passe par le sas centre
de rétention administrative et et et
cette priorisation me semble essentielle
voilà donc
je pense qu'il faut soit des centres de
rétention spécifique soit trouver un
moyen pour que parce que la difficulté
c'est que les consulats deviennent pas
dans les prisons pour reconnaître les
nationalités délivrer les c'est pas sûr
il y a besoin de trouver une solution
qui doit être probablement législative
pour faire en sorte que
cette situation la situation des
sortants de prison qui sont délinquants
qui n'ont pas de titre de séjour et qui
qui doivent être éloignés puissent être
éloignés de manière prioritaire et pas
finalement avec l'ensemble des autres
rachelinez vous étiez en reportage pour
Marianne vous avez passé une journée
dans cette Cour nationale du droit
d'asile pour les juges c'est pas simple
de faire le tri entre
ceux qui justement parce qu'il y a des
délinquants il y a des personnes qui
sont en cours de de condamnation et qui
et qui joue des recours possibles pour
continuer dans des asiles c'est ce que
j'ai compris en lisant Antarctique là
alors plusieurs choses pour établir un
petit cadre qu'on parle tout ce qu'on
puisse tous parler de la même chose être
en situation irrégulière en France n'est
pas considérée comme un délit si je me
trompe pas ça date de 2012 premier point
deuxième ensuite lorsqu'on est demandeur
d'asile on est des photos en situation
régulière et pas irrégulières se pose
néanmoins la question des déboutés
c'est-à-dire des gens pour qui belofpra
n'a pas accordé une protection qui ont
parfois fait un recours devant la TVA et
le recours devant la CNDA pardon la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile
a été a été en continuité a été dans le
sens de de l'OFPRA la plupart ne vont
pas plus loin en termes en termes de
recours donc il y a en effet ces
individus là qui parfois alors certains
peuvent bénéficier dans notre titre mais
certains n'en n'ont pas d'autres et se
posent la question d'où l'éloignement
qui dans la large majorité des cas n'est
pas effectué ne peut être effectuée il
n'y a pas les fameux laisser passer
consulaires etc ensuite oui il y a
certains cas ça veut pas dire c'est la
majorité mais qui se présentent j'en ai
vu à la Cour nationale du droit d'asile
et qui sont en attente de jugement ça
peut être pour pour meurtre pour
tentative de meurtre pour viol violence
etc parce que ce n'est pas parce déjà
ils sont présumées innocents et c'est
important de le dire et puis ensuite on
peut très bien être un délinquant et
obtenir une protection parce que la
protection le droit ou la protection
subsidiaire elle est donnée dans la
mesure où on estime que si on renvoie la
personne dans son pays d'origine elle
risque elle risque de sévices
extrêmement important voire même la mort
et donc la France protège ses gens là
ils ne vont pas être exemptés non plus
de peine de prison qu'on soit clair mais
c'est une situation que peut rencontrer
la Cour nationale du droit d'asile et je
vous en prie très vite il y a il y a
quand même et ça a été renforcé au cours
des 10 dernières années des suivis
sécuritaires au moment de l'OFPRA avec
un certain nombre de de filtrage
d'informations à l'OFPRA deux procédures
contradictoires à la CNDA pour faire en
sorte que l'OFPRA soit représenté à la
CNDA dès lors que la personne représente
un danger donc je crois que sur les
questions sur les questions des
personnes qui représenteraient un danger
et qui pour le coup donc
on ne vous enfin en tout cas l'autorité
publique ne souhaite pas voir
à qui l'autorité il ne souhaite pas que
l'asile soit accordée là c'est bien
entendu est souveraine mais l'offrey est
représenté et un certain nombre
d'informations sont données donc
vraiment fait attention à cette question
sécurité ce qui était essentielle je
suis désolé de vous interrompre je l'ai
peut-être ouvert trop tard cette
question droit d'Asie je vais faire on
met un couple pas parce que ça demande
un peu plus de temps et de complexité
mais on a entendu à l'un et à l'autre de
vos arguments merci beaucoup à bientôt
sur sur public